welcome to this video i'm playing a
limerick here russia russian black at
least so looks like an open season and
okay time on off that's not the line
that ad like so much i have to play for
a head shop now at least it's an air
chalkware whitest move that night a
couple of times but my night on sorry on
c6 is also not exactly correct hmm and
maybe do it immediately we root that
Knight to d7
I'm not sure that this leads to much I
mean he can attack b6 and that's it I
night a for maybe night a4 was a move
there hmm
hmm interesting anyway let's not be too
irritated night a for my ipod Bishop c6
probably some something like that maybe
even bishop the ADA everything else
fails
I can play 95 and kick him back but i'm
not sure if i want i still have that
queen bee eight Bishop d8 style maneuver
that is played there quite often I'm
going for that if he takes b6 now I'm
going to take on b6 Cody 54 Bishop c5 so
it's not on at all ok you regroup that
night but it's not entirely clear
whereas heading I them that was there
did it was the idea ok mmm so what now
can I switch to that rook GA g5 plan I
always liked that idea
so I he doesn't mind that I'm going I'm
going for it the rook g6 possibly g4
it's an interesting way to complicate
the whole thing okay g6 he has some good
reply now so maybe start with this 95
was also also an option but the
opportunity to to arrange the looks like
doubling or route 87 route g8 this make
us make some sense i believe
ok so G for Bishop h6 is not helping me
and let's put that here see if I can use
it on the moon see if I can use it on
the King side okay well I don't like
them if it takes and cannot be a big
issue
or thinking h4 night h5 things like that
yeah that the g5 plan is one of the few
active plants that on black hairs in
those hedgehogs I mean active in the
sense of really that you can do it
without reacting to something that why
does it's not that black is totally
passive it just quite often the case
that you have to yeah basically and wait
what why does and then have then react
accordingly okay I was covering v6 I
think you're probably really threatened
to take its own cover that pawn be
before might be an option I know c4l see
forehead doesn't hang a four or a five
yeah that might be a tricky that move
maybe not a good idea wow really
niger careful night shift for okay
anyway i will go in the long diagonal
here that that should be right g16 g8
would be nice getting out of that
diagonal but ok that that's going to
explode now any anyway this whole thing
ok let's cover really do that we r FG
for at the end of this procedure rope
the six maybe rope the section that went
throught the aid ok 97 oh yeah night XD
for all right jack now let's see still
attacking that bloody g6 porn and how to
play up to success immediately
threatening on the edge
and maybe this huh covering stuff I
didn't see anything much better
ninety-two was an issue 994 would be
excellent to get in I cannot play it now
check takes 95
no it's probably just good for wide if
he plays it correctly but he's really
hampered by its time so down to 10
seconds something like that time working
wind f3 no room shakes okay check like
forehead one at one point he should it
was on time and if his on- something
with all the time um jab a super
complicated position out of this
Hedgehog let's look at some critical
moments this this is g5 plan i'm not
sure about but as I said it's one of the
few active ideas that black has and it's
it's often interesting to play I think
we played that totally okay page 5 and
so on it's it's it's definitely risky
business g3 surprised me I was thinking
that this must help me man that the long
diagonal is so much weakened the
computer wants to go h4 now that is
interesting and the idea is to take on
g3 and after this switch to a dark
square to play with a 595 it's
interesting definitely yeah I wanted to
use that long diagonal but it doesn't
work here this is the computer reply
and black falls apart huh so I cannot
take and then that is bad news if I have
to play Bishop da door LA now so he
could have refuted my my queen a8 with
95 age for whatever was ok so 95 this
now it was working again again it way
it's difficult and here the position is
really a collapsing quite a bit ok this
is a mistake it seems 97's better and
then check with the bishop modifiers can
do that hmm what did you what did you
have engine gives King g1 Wow
yeah that wins now a position feel shaky
for black really odd as this is
vulnerable and those rooks I cut off
very really place check this however and
now I really have nothing much better
than this but it's better after every
five also after that but ok lost some
time there and so yeah this is sometimes
the problem if you're sitting in this
Hedgehog position time and you want to
do something sometimes killing yourself
a little bit ok well thanks for watching